on vient de le voir dans un ted
tout est permis à propos de permis vous
le connaissez ces papiers rose c'est le
le permis de conduire on a bon public ce
soir
bien joué et celui-ci papier rose qui
lui ressemble le permis d'être semaine
plus connaissez pas vraiment c'est
normal je viens de l'inventer
je viens de l'inventer parce que dans ma
vie j'ai une chance incroyable c'est de
rencontrer plein de jeunes dans ma vie
professionnelle je veux dans une
entreprise depuis trente ans je recrute
des étudiants l'alternance qui ont passé
une année avec moi dans l'entreprise est
une année en cours dans les écoles dans
les universités où j'interviens parfois
et puis surtout dans mon club je suis
président d'un club de foot est à peu
près 250 membres 100 jeunes qui ont
entre 6 et 18 ans 40 encadrants
j'adore les voir tous différents plein
d'énergie
j'adore ça il ya un truc qui m'énerve
c'est quand je les vois arriver dans le
monde de l'entreprise
au bout de quinze jours ce sont des
clones
ce sont des clones des copies conformes
de ceux qui sont là depuis 20 ans ça
m'énerve je ne supporte pas c'est un
vrai gâchis dans mon club par exemple il
ya ryan ryan et la 12 ans
son entraîneur a décidé de le faire d'en
faire le capitaine de son équipe
l'air de rien ryan c'est un manager
c'est le porte parole de ses copains
dans le vestiaire dans les coulisses
porte parole auprès de l'entraîneur
porte parole auprès de l' arbitre c'est
même le seul qui a le droit de parler à
l'arbitré
sinon les autres ses cartons après
de larbitre chez nous on en a il
s'appelle zakaria savait qu'elle agit là
zakaria zakaria notre arbitre officiel
il a 15 ans ça fait un an qu'il arbitres
déjà il a commencé à 14
et du coup le mois dernier je lui ai
posé la question zakaria ça fait quel
effet d'être arbitre vous savez ce qui
m'a répondu ce super sur le terrain je
suis le patron
zakaria 15 ans patron d'une pme de 30
joueurs tous les week-ends quand je vois
ces jeunes qui prennent des
responsabilités et quand je les vois
dans l'entreprise qui arrivent tous
timoré qui ont peur je me dis c'est
quand même pas je peux pas laisser faire
ça vous connaissez la différence entre
le monde du sport finalement et le monde
de l'entreprise où elle est la
différence dans les tripes dans les
tripes du joueur 10 bat toute l'espèce
qui s'entraîne dur pour avoir sa place
pour jouer collectif dans les tripes de
l'entraîneur qui lui il a envie de
transmettre avec passion tout ce qu'il a
appris dans les entreprises elles sont
où les tripes avec le mot il n'existe
pas c'est un monde feutré
surtout ne pas faire de bruit le jeune
il arriver oui il a peur car pour se
rassurer ils haïssent et dignité les
autres il va essayer de respecter les
fameux code de l'entreprise
une vraie horreur il va oublier d'être
lui-même un jeune étudiant qui arrive
dans le monde professionnel
en fait c'est un jeune plus à vivre une
nouvelle crise d'adolescence la crise
d'adolescence professionnels et pour
l'aider à surpasser cette crise
d'adolescence professionnels ben
justement j'ai inventé ce fameux permis
le permis d'être soi même et j'ai même
développé ni beau point une méthode en
quatre étapes et je leur fais passer
quatre étapes
première étape le prénom et de rêver
c'est un
pourtant les rêves deuxième étape le
permis de se planter très important de
se planter
troisième étape le permis de réussir
4e étape le permis de s'assumer
la première étape c'est le permis de
rêver c'est comme le permis de conduire
moi je me souviens très bien
en fait ça a commencé quand j'étais à
l'arrière de la voiture mes parents je
les voyais conduire et je rêvais du jour
je passerai devant et puis ce jour il
arrive un jour on passe le permis de
conduire on a le droit de prendre le
volant
c'est la première fois de l'eau dit
qu'on peut conduire sans que quelqu'un
nous dise tourner à droite
tourner à gauche et on peut aller où on
veut qu'on y aille ou qu'on y aille pas
d'ailleurs c'est pas important
on sait qu'on peut y aller tout est
possible dans mon entreprise le dernier
apprentis que j'ai accompagné simple et
benjamin benjamin quand il est arrivé on
a fait un premier point dossiers dans
mon propre des points dossier je vais
demander quoi d'adn me raconter ses
rêves
finalement c'était quoi son rêve
dans quelle entreprise il rêvait de
bosser quel métier rêvé de faire et puis
finalement en dehors de la vie
professionnelle c'est quoi ces patients
est ce qui fait vivre par les je voyais
ses yeux brillent et du coup j'en ai
profité je vais parler de mon parcours
professionnel ma vie associative et de
mon envie justement de l'aider à devenir
lui-même et c'était justement sam on va
être d'aider les autres à être un peu
plus ce même savoir écouter ses rêves
c'est important parce que quand on sait
les écouter
en fait on en prend aux tripes qui
parlent à notre cerveau le permis de
rêver la deuxième étape c'est le permis
de se planter
quand on arrive dans ce monde de
l'entreprise on n'a pas le droit de se
planter
pourtant quand vous faites un jeu vidéo
quand vous êtes un match de foot
des fois vous gagnez des fois vous
perdez c'est pas grave vous entraînez
vous passez à l'étape suivante et ça
finit par passer
mais dans l'entreprise ou à l'école
banon ne l'avait pas noir zéro pointé
comment voulez vous aider un jeune à
réussir si la paloise se plante et cela
même pas le droit de prendre des risques
c'est pas vraiment difficile pourtant
donc qu'est ce que je fais je leur fais
passer ce fameux permis de planter au
bout de quelques temps je leur fais
passer un autre étape qui me semble
encore plus importante s'est permis de
réussir mais pour passer de l'un à
l'autre
comment ça se passe en fait benjamin au
bout de quelques temps je lui demande de
mme écrire un article sur un article
auquel sur un événement auquel il avait
participé à l'événement plutôt sympa
c'était sur le sport avec des valides et
non valides
il m'a écrit un article il l'a montré
je dis waouh benjamin ces cas le premier
article de ta vie professionnelle que tu
es en train d'écrire
or chez qui a plus d'albums photos mais
bon tu as peut-être le partager sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est super important
alors je lui ai dit que cache ce que je
pensais de son article c'était terrible
en fait il m'avait écrit une note de
service note de synthèse l'entreprise
intel a fait tel truc tel jour et j'ai
dit mais c'est fou je t'ai vu pense
d'événements tu appartiens à participer
à toutes les activités
tu avais la balance a rencontré plein de
gens donc au bout d'un moment je vais
laisser trois jours pour rester à
l'article au bout de trois jours il l'a
montré
c'était super
c'était super en fait qu'est ce qu'ils
avaient fait pas en trois jours il avait
téléphoné il avait appelé les
participants il avait appelé les
partenaires
il avait même écrit l'article à la
première personne un super témoignages
benjamin en fait qu'est ce qui s'était
passé
je l'avais en fait aidé à se planter je
l'avais aidé à se planter
mais je l'avais surtout et des avoirs
qui s'était planté
et je l'avais des avoirs qui s'était
planté mais je l'avais aussi beaucoup
aidé à voir qu'il avait en lui les
ressources pour trouver une solution
sa solution aider quelqu'un à réussir en
fait c'est d'abord coupé le cordon week
end en coupant le cordon ombilical
c'est le meilleur moyen d'éviter de
reproduire le clone de vous même le
permis de ce nous permet de rêver
le permis de se planter le permis de
réussir la quatrième étape s'est permis
de s'assumer
benjamin il est à gauche mais aussi à
droite
ils sont formidables le permet d'assumer
quand je regarde autour de moi il ya
quelque chose que je ne supporte pas
dans ce monde de l'entreprise au bout de
quelques semaines oui il a pris un peu
confiance mais il n'est pas autonome
d'un jamin c'est un vrai problème
du coup j'ai essayé de comprendre
comment on pouvait rendre les gens
autonomes
donc j'ai regardé j'essaie de trouver
autour de moi et puis finalement j'ai
pas eu à regarder bien loin j'ai regardé
mon épouse et les kinésithérapeutes
comment ça se passe quand on part en
vacances quand on part en vacances
elle passe une annonce à l'école de kiné
recherche jeunes kinés sortant de
l'école pour faire un remplacement elle
le rencontre la veille
elle lui explique le cas des différents
patients les différents dossiers
elle lui donne les clefs et le soir
quand on part en vacances et le
lendemain on est sur les pistes et lui
ils soignent les patients en toute
confiance que je me suis masse pourquoi
ça marche chez les professions libérales
pourquoi j'arrive pas à le faire dans
l'entreprise
donc du coup j'ai essayé de mettre au
point une autre
cette technique justement c'est ce que
j'appelle couper le cordon ombilical
benjamin au bout de quelques temps il
doit organiser une réunion à laquelle je
dois participer
une réunion sera dossier qu'il maîtrise
qui gère en responsabilité justement et
un goût un moment la veille au soir au
dernier moment en fait je viens lorsque
je suis plus là que je peux pas être là
j'ai un empêchement jeu quand je le
plante mais je le rassure tout de suite
c'est son dossier il a toutes les
capacités je sais qu'il va arriver à le
faire et à votre avis évidemment le
lendemain il parvient parfaitement animé
sa réunion c'est important de couper ce
cordon ombilical
la dernière étape ce fameux permis de
s'assumer qui on est qui on veut être
qui ont choisi d'être qui on assume
d'être je voulais dit je donne des cours
et j'interviens dans des écoles et
auprès des étudiants également j'aime
bien les faire travailler en sous
groupes et au bout d'un moment je les
interrompt landes mende
c'est quand même bizarre pourquoi vous
être réparti les garçons d'un côté les
filles de l'autre
alors je leur demande de se mélanger
je leur laisse retravailler qui est au
bout d'un moment je les interrompt bout
de 2 minutes et rien que vous dérange
c'est quand même bizarre dans tous les
sous-groupes c'est une fille qui prend
les notes je suis pas là pour leur faire
une leçon de morale
moi ce que je veux c'est juste les aider
les forces et analyser la situation
présente il en rate pas vouloir se
mélanger c'est pas mon problème c'est un
problème c'est leur problème mais ce
n'est pas l'enjeu
ce qui m'importe c'est qu'ils prennent
une décision et à ce moment là ils ont
le choix soit de se re mélanger ou de
changer la personne qui va prendre des
notes soin de laisser en l'état
peu importe ils ont une décision à
prendre et à assumer une vision à
prendre de faire ou de ne pas faire le
permis de rêver le permis de se planter
le permis de réussir le permis de
s'assumer
une fois qu'on a fait passer ses quatre
étapes on est déjà un peu plus haut un
peu dur car si vous avez peut-être et
pisani-ferry chat permet de pomper
permis d'être soit gris à l'impératrice
en fait rien en terme de longueur
on vous le donne le permis d'être soi
même tout au long de sa vie on peut
essayer de se l'accordé
et il ya un point commun dans les deux
c'est qu'il ya un moniteur qui vous
accompagne pour le permis de conduire un
moniteur d'auto école pour le permis
d'être soi-même un moniteur d'école de
la vie
les moniteurs d'école de la vie on en
rencontre tous dans notre vie pas
beaucoup moins d'une dizaine
moi je me souviens le premier que j'ai
rencontré je le savais d'ailleurs pas à
l'époque j'avais neuf ans c'était mon
instit daniel jurquet cm1 cm2 le lundi
matin il proposait aux élèves qu'il
voulait devenir raconter ce qui l'avait
fait le week end
moi j'étais plutôt un élève moyen
c'était rare que j'aille volontairement
au tableau noir
et puis un jour j'ai quand même j'ai
décidé d'y aller alors j'ai raconté mon
week end j'ai raconté mon match de foot
j'ai raconté mes expéditions en vélo
avec les amis etc et j'ai vu ses yeux
qui brillaient c'était la première fois
qu'un adulte s'intéresser à ma vie le
lendemain j'étais plus le même une part
de moi avait pris confiance en elle
l'air derrière daniel jurquet c'était la
première personne qui m'a aidé à
m'accorder mon premier permis d'être moi
même
alors ce soir devant vous je m'offre le
permis de rêver à voix haute
on est quatre cent dans cette salle vous
imaginez s'ils ont décidé tous ensemble
de s'accorder ce fameux permis d'être
soi même et si chaque fois qu'on entend
le mot permis c'est terminé c'est pas
permis
on prend
à ce permis d'être soi même vous
imaginez si en sortant ce soir on était
quatre sans moniteur d'école de la vie
pour nos gosses pour nos jeunes et
pourquoi pas
tout est possible tout est permis merci
[Applaudissements]